welcome back i'll now do a couple of
more momentum problems so this first
problem i have this ice skater and she's
on an ice skating rink and what she's
doing is she's holding a ball and this
ball let me draw the ball
this is a .15 kilogram ball it's a point
one five kilogram ball and she throws it
she throws it let's just say she throws
it directly uh straight forward in front
of her although she's staring at us
she's actually forward for her body so
she's she throws it exactly
straight forward i understand it is hard
to throw something straight forward but
let's assume that she can
so she throws it exactly straight
forward with a speed or since we're
going to give the direction as well it's
a velocity right because speed is just
the magnitude while a velocity is a
magnitude and a direction
so she throws the ball at 35
meters per second
and this ball is
.15 kilograms
now what the problem says is that their
combined mass
their combined mass
her plus the ball
is 50 kilograms
50 kilograms and the question is
after she throws the ball so they're
both stationary before she does anything
and then she throws this ball
and the question is after throwing this
ball what is her recoil velocity or
essentially how much by throwing the
ball did does she push herself backwards
so what is her velocity in the backward
direction
and if you're not familiar with the the
term recoil recoil it's often applied to
when someone i guess you know not that
we want to think about violent things
but if you shoot a gun your shoulder
recoils back because
once again momentum is conserved so
there's a certain amount of momentum
going into that bullet which is very
light and fast going forward but since
momentum is conserved your shoulder has
has velocity backwards but we will do
another problem with that let's get back
to this problem so like i just said
momentum is conserved so what's the
momentum at the start of the problem so
the initial momentum well let's say
let's make let's let me do different
color so this is the initial momentum
initially
the mass is 50 kilograms
right because we're in the ball combined
or 50 kilograms
times the velocity well the velocity is
zero
so initially there is zero velocity in
the system zero velocity
so the momentum
is zero p equals let's say p initial
is equal to zero
and since we start with a net zero
momentum
we have to finish with a net zero
momentum so what's momentum later
we have a ball moving at 35 meters per
second and the ball has a mass of 0.15
kilograms
so it's .15
i'll ignore the units for now just to
save space times the velocity of the
ball
times
35 meters per second
so this is the momentum of the ball
plus the new momentum of the figure
skater so what's her her mass well her
mass is going to be 50 minus this
actually won't matter a ton but let's
say it's 49
49 point what is that 0.85
kilograms
times her new velocity
times velocity let's call that the
velocity of the skater
and so let me get my trusty
calculator out
okay
so let's see 0.15 times 35 so let's see
0.15 times
35 is equal to 5.25
so that equals
5.25
plus
49.85
times the skater's velocity the final
velocity and of course this equals zero
because the initial velocity was zero
so let's uh
i don't know subtract 0.5.25 from both
sides and then the equation becomes
minus
5.25 is equal to 49.85
times the velocity of the skater
so essentially saying that the momentum
of just the just the ball is 5.25 and
since we have a since the combined
system has to have zero net momentum
we're saying that the momentum of the
skater has to be 5.25 in the other
direction going backwards or has a
momentum of minus
5.25
and to figure out the velocity we just
divide her momentum by her mass
and so divide both sides by 49.85 and
you get
the velocity of the skater
so let's see let's make this a negative
number
divided by 49.85
equals
minus 0.105
so minus
point
minus is a little too low ignore minus
.105
meters per second
so that's interesting when she throws
this ball um out at 35 meters per second
which is pretty fast she will recoil
back at about well about 10 centimeters
about yeah roughly 10 centimeters per
second so she will recoil a lot slower
although she will move back and if you
think about it this is this is a form of
propulsion this is how rockets work they
eject something
that maybe has less mass but super fast
and that since we have a conservational
momentum it it makes the rocket move in
the other direction
anyway let's see if we could do fit
another problem in this actually it's
probably better to leave this problem
done and then i'll have more time for
the next problem which will be
slightly more difficult see you soon